you just finished a show on on Broadway
on the 20th century I did and that's got
to be grueling
I mean Broadway shows I've never had an
experience like that I do this every day
it you know we work on it for a couple
hours and then we do the taping for an
hour but a Broadway show night after
night after night where you're singing
your lungs out that's got to be tough
it's it's incredibly difficult and
singing our lungs out indeed is what we
do right it doesn't matter you can be
sick you still I mean if you're really
sick you get an you get someone else to
come in but you really want to try and I
like recently I cracked a rib when I was
on Broadway not a lot of people know
that but you know even that like if you
just go if you have a rib anybody that
knows less how to hurt rib forget about
it but I was awkward to Peter Gallagher
who we know and love right yeah he's
terrific
he's got the breath he's got the
thickest eyebrows he never knows when
it's snowing it all collects up here he
has to get a broom and knock it down but
he's he's brilliant a brilliant
performer in fact I said bow to the
eyebrows I said oh your brows are just
amazing and they just get more and more
as you age he's like hey thanks be shut
up and I just realized that people live
my whole life I thought whatever is
staring at my smile because I have a
good smile right but I just realized
they were looking at my brow no no he's
got Oscar the Grouch brows that go up
and down you know we both got sick a lot
you know as time goes on we have fog on
our show it's filthy dirty sometimes in
those theaters and he got sick and he
had phlegm but you know big phlegm ball
and and I kind of tell it was coming Oh
bro you know every time I come in here I
have to say something to that saying I
don't mean for it to happen yeah but um
my parents are again so proud but I he
coughed up a Libby and all he's singing
on oh and here it comes
almost as in slow motion
thank you you guys it was coming towards
you yeah it totally spin spun spun fun I
was like where's it gonna land where's
they gonna like could it be on my chest
gonna be on my cheek landed here are my
role is if it's clear him and I are good
if it's three you're sick yeah yeah yeah
so what would you what was it well good
Wow Jim I was realizing I don't have any
rules about what kind of phlegm people
spit on